right here on the Rich Eisen show in his
12th season as general manager of the
Houston Rockets daryl morey how are you
sir I'm great thanks from the on risk
I've been admirer of yours as well so
thank you Twitter I guess it's good for
something it's I mean I always learn so
much about politics on Twitter I you
know I get so much informed debates it's
really really helpful to debate people
on Twitter well I'm you know a lot of
people say Derral that NBA Twitter is
the most entertaining Twitter that is
out there
Twitter's get it politics Twitter that
needs to be avoided at all cost I think
well I guess there's there's a filter
for that and at or or calling into the
Rich Eisen show at this very moment you
you have called in what what are you up
to these days what does what does Daryl
Morey do for the Houston Rockets at this
very time of year right now I'm sitting
in a bus outside I can get quiet
background hit press associate that well
yeah we're buzzing here I mean we I mean
I know it's I know everyone says
everyone's happy in October but you know
the the buzz here is I mean we're very
confident at this point we're better
than last year and obviously we're going
to need to prove that but every you know
a lot of the new folks we brought in are
really showing us stuff and you know
we're we're excited well we got a deal
when the rubber meets the road though
we're buzzing and and the phones are
buzzing - I mean it's a pretty active
spearpoint NBA twitter right now given
the camp just started usually usually
not a much buzz but there's a lot of a
lot of lot of trade buzz in there guys
have to say that I want to kind of want
to hit that with you and I know that
it's probably a sensitive subject but it
word is that you are in on the Jimmy
Butler sweepstakes is that a fact
yeah it's like I can't really just
directly address it but I will say I
mean obviously whatever there's whatever
there's players potentially available
that can help
you know the Houston Rockets it's my job
to explore but I would say we love our
team so I mean I you know we're we're
pretty focused on what we got but you
know what else am i doing except trying
to explore everything that's that's
really what they pay me to do well then
let me ask you this question based on
what you might be able to talk about do
you think Jimmy Butler is in fact
available do you think that they do
really want to get rid of him up there
in Minnesota if you can address that
yeah I hate unfortunately like the NBA
rules or so so so you know I can't even
I can't talk about players and other
teams apologize I can't make news today
you know combine or whatever that might
make I see that would be great so the
metric so to use the analytics of this
is it's full blue tarski zero point zero
of you being able to address the
situation I did I get out okay so in
terms of the guys that you did acquire
that are they're under contract you told
the Houston Chronicle that a high
percentage of the decisions you made
this offseason were in mind to beat the
Warriors how how does that all compute
with the guys that you got yeah I mean
we know that if we're gonna win the
title it's almost for sure we're gonna
have to be on stage we got to beat a lot
other teams but you know if they've won
three out of the last four to the road
you know the road goes through Golden
State I mean there's no there's no
spinning that and so yeah the you know
James Anna's Carmelo Anthony Michael
carter-williams
you know they're all Brandon Knight we
haven't had a chance to see yet Marquis
Chris is doing well on camp for me where
they're all like sitting in like quickly
and you know we're excited about them I
would say both
maybe Melo and James Ennis are both both
really standouts early here in camp why
are you so open about talking
the Warriors Darryl I just I think it's
weird to not talk about like if you like
rich if you cast a fan on the street and
you get to do that a lot I think and you
said you know what should the Houston
Rockets be doing and they were saying
well geez you know the Warriors are so
good they gotta be like it's like almost
silly to not talk about it right I mean
there they are historically great team
maybe we'll go down as the best NBA team
ever so it seems to me it just he'd have
to be incomplete GM speed coach speak to
not talk about the Warriors and then
talk about how we have to beat them so
what do you think is the way to beat
them Darryl based on what you have your
analog I think we're the only way
possible which is you've you know you've
got to be able to space the floor she's
the three got to be able to be in
transition you have to have players you
can do can guard multiple positions and
then stay with you know coach Kerr does
a great job and their offensive system
there's a lot of movement you've got to
have guys who can play and defend those
so yeah we feel like we've got the the
best approach but you know frankly we
obviously haven't done it so but as soon
as someone does it you know we'll we'll
try and copy that if that happens but
hopefully that's us hopefully everyone's
kept on us what about the amassing of
bona fide all-star players the so-called
super team yeah that's the huge part of
it I mean and to go back to what we
talked about earlier when when
potentially there are players available
I you know my job my staffs I was to
look at that for that reason the only
you know the only way to beat the USA
basketball team is to you know have the
USA basketball one-eight you know have
the 181 B team and I have the one a
scheme right you know that the team in
practice so I mean yeah we we need to
have as much talent as possible and
sometimes it doesn't always work but it
really gives us it gives us a chance
we're not having a highly talented squad
you know you may as well pack it in
daryl morey here on the Rich Eisen show
do you think if Chris Paul's hamstring
had not given way you'd have knocked off
the Warriors last year you know we do
believe
obviously that's uncertain warriors
because you know they could have beat us
with Chris healthy and they had it all
out and but you know it would have been
nice
given they have you know arguably for
the top players in the league and then
we I think are pretty comfortable that
we have two of the top players in the
league it would have been nice if the
injury Luck had gone the other way where
we're at least knocking them down two
down to three guys instead of Goss going
from two to one so so ya know we do
believe that we would have done that but
you know you know injuries are part of
the games I mean they want it and you
know we're chasing them down this year
again it were Chris Paul and and harden
it all part of the acquisition of
Carmelo absolutely I mean we one of the
things that I think is helped make us
successful is you know at at the end of
the day the NBA teams are all about your
top players and they've got to set the
culture they've got to be the ones who
really set the tone for everything and
to do that they've got to feel like
they're part of everything so we you
know I have discussions with them about
about everything just like I do with our
head coach at the end of the day
obviously myself and you know until men
you know where we're making the final
calls but James Chris coach Dan Tony
they're absolutely critical to any
acquisition we make and if we don't if
they don't feel like it's gonna fit we
may still to it but it's pretty rare I
mean it we want everyone on the same
page everyone bought in and that's been
a big part of ours well one way to prove
about buying is to potentially sacrifice
for the larger good the carmelo bench
questions were shut down by him in
Oklahoma City what about there in
Houston is it possible he comes off as a
six man yeah you know that's what the
coach coach is still figuring out what
he thinks will work best I mean you know
so one of the great things about our
season last year where were the 1 seed
and and and 65 wins and a hamstring away
from winning it is every player on
team was willing to take any role and
that's true again this year and then you
know coach is going to figure out the
best rotations but you know no matter
what Eric guys like Eric Gordon who came
off the bench last year Ryan Anderson is
our starter came off the bench last year
I mean we've got we've got good players
coming off the bench we got good players
starting and a big part of our success
is every player has been willing to been
willing to do anything and so Melo may
start Melanie come on the bench so the
other coach then Tony but we have not
figured that out yet so what was your
reaction when you look down at Twitter
or what have you the day let LeBron
signed with the Lakers and you knew he
was coming to your conference daryl
morey yeah you know obviously someone
every team would love to have so just
first first thing is obviously now we
know I never chance Adam but yeah I'm
not he's he's an amazing amazing player
and so we're you know it's gonna make it
that that much harder in the West at
least at least one trait one player when
he in in Kauai so at least we we
balanced it a little but you know
LeBron's obviously LeBron and that you
know it's gonna be another tough out in
the Western Conference I mean I'm used
to it I mean my whole career I've been
in league I came in 2002 so the West is
in the best you know conference ever
since I've been in the league so pretty
normal I'm just trying to pick up did
you think you had a shot at getting
abroad were you ready to pitch or did
you try to manually we go for everybody
we're not yeah I mean we're not we're
not Vicki you know we want you at the
Rockets we feel like if we get a chance
to talk to you we get a chance for you
to understand what we're trying to do
that we've got a real shot and so
obviously we strike out a lot but we
also swing a lot and everyone sarong we
hit we hit one out with a click like we
did with James and Chris and and
hopefully guys down the road so just to
get to continue that metaphor did you
get in the batter's box did you take a
hack at getting LeBron I you know you
never you never know you never know we
you know we weren't we weren't I don't
think we're really
in the mix like we would like to be I
don't yeah in this case I don't think we
were we were we were sort of we were due
up I think when when when he went
somewhere else on deck in the hole I
mean we yeah I think we're I think we're
on deck with a couple teams daryl morey
here on the Rich Eisen show all right
down so are you in a fantasy football
league
are you a farce man people ask me all
the time they're like you know your your
job so hard and everything I try to I
try to explain it well first off my job
is not hard my job is you you have to do
it well but it's obviously a dream and
then second if people play fantasy
football fantasy baseball it's it's it's
not very different it's about making
very solid decisions obviously there's
you got to be really good with people
and things like that but you don't need
to do it fantasy but but in terms of
like the decision-making and understand
scarcity and working trades and all that
that that all is actually more analogous
and than anyone else will actually
usually admit and so III it's actually
one of our interview when we talk to
people to come to the Rockets we asked
them about their fantasy football
strategies come on because it really
gives us a sense of how they think so
yes I am infinite before what do you
learn from people like what you are you
more apt to hire somebody who does not
take a quarterback in the first four
rounds of their draft I mean like what
do you glean from that subject matter so
in our interview process everywhere I'll
just say thank you know that's rich
everyone is terrible at interviewing
that's like proven and and so we're just
trying to get a little bit less than
terrible and what I like to do is is to
hear how people think so I actually
don't care if they take a quarterback in
the first round the six out they take a
kicker early you can just walk that way
you defend the interview sir but but if
they're taking a quarterback there are
there are ways to explain taking a
quarterback girl I think generally it's
a bad strategy but as long as you give a
thoughtful answer we might we might keep
talking if you give a good answer I want
I don't know if I'd want to be in a
fantasy league with one of the top
analytical
in sports I don't know if I'd want to be
in a league with you Darryl who's in
your league Oh College High School work
friends over the years yeah we've we've
been in together since 94 maybe
something like that not MIT northwestern
is we're saying or northwestern some
work friends against the Rockets you
know how it is
if you don't play well though you're out
man I'm ruthless I'm the commissioner so
like you don't if you know if you're not
keeping up with your team or whatever
we're we're moving on to someone else
how are you like a commissioner more
Stern than silver or more silver than
Stern what type of you commissioner
you know you know commissioners
unbelievable and I love this style but I
got to say I'm more I don't have time so
I'm more David Stern as a guy just like
you know people are like making
suggestions I'm like now we're not
saying that on time time to worry about
your your concerns yeah so okay just I
guess last one for you on this what is
your strategy for a fantasy I'm curious
as somebody who uses analytics and knows
it as well I like sort of like the Jimmy
Butler trade I don't want to get you in
any trouble you know just talk generally
yeah you know I well you're gonna get me
in trouble I mean it's not like my
fantasy football jerseys or anything
anyone should care about but yeah I like
the early lock-in at top receiver and in
round one or two because I I worked the
waiver wire a lot so I usually can snag
one of these young running back to those
murders later by working the waiver wire
so I want to get one solid running back
and one side receiver and rounds one and
two you can't always do it based on
where you support where things play but
I look there and then you know and then
I don't actually really worried about
quarterback till later unless there's a
real top one maybe in round three still
still hanging out there and then unless
I can get a unique to get defense or tie
down I wait till late there I usually
sit on the the I sit on the you know the
handcuffs of like you know teams with
great offensive lines usually like in
the first or second year guy who's
sitting behind it great offensive line
and then and then wait for one of the
top running backs go out and then yeah
and then you're essentially yeah usually
by the end you're
and then you got to get lucky in the
playoffs like like like they saw this
but Daryl Morey and you have you won
your league have you won yeah I think
I've won four times
[Laughter]
fantasy football four times that's like
yeah you know what I got twenty foul
balls when I go to baseball games and
it's oh come on man that was very casual
I like that yeah yeah now we have good
league if they I sure your in one Syria
what you want we might have someone to
kick out if you wanna down I would do it
if you if you are kicking anybody out of
your league if you're David's turning
somebody ok I'm in ok let me add but
we'll chat much more before than I
really have enjoyed this and throw that
we have connected thanks for calling it
thank you got it that is the reigning
NBA executive of the year down Lori the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience